we bring in Chris hein he covers the
Minnesota Timberwolves at least he's
just started covering the Minnesota
Timberwolves from the Minneapolis
star-tribune
Chris kind enough to join us how would
you sum up yesterday what happened with
Jimmy Butler management and the rest of
the players you could kind of see this
coming from a mile away it's been three
weeks since Jimmy Butler made a request
of the organization to trade him and in
three weeks we've heard rumors of
various potential deals but nothing has
gotten done we've heard reports that and
we've reported that you know Tom
Thibodeau has been reluctant at times to
deal Butler hoping to force his way back
onto the team we've heard that Glen
Taylor wants to get a deal done and so
this whole kind of messy situation came
to a head yesterday where we're getting
close to the regular season Butler has
to come back and improve he's healthy
and still a top 15 player in the league
and he came in yesterday and he had a
message for his teammates he had a
message for the front office and then
ESPN happened to be in town yesterday
and he sat down for energy with them to
really explain his feelings for the
first time and so yesterday was kind of
a culmination of everything that's been
building for the last three weeks
who has the leverage here good question
the NBA is a player's league and and so
I think ultimately the players have the
lever in the situation if Jimmy Butler
wants to kind of pull a Kawhi Leonard
and claim that his surgically repaired
wrist is bothering and he can sit out
potentially and still get paid while the
Wolves try to work on a deal for him I
do think that that he has the leverage I
don't think the Wolves have a ton of
leverage and trade talks with other
teams now looked like they were making
some progress on that front with Miami
last week so we'll see if those talks
resume they were called off over the
weekend but Miami's trying to get back
and get those started again so we'll see
what happens here but I do think that
ultimately if Jimmy Butler doesn't want
to be here he will not be here
that's why I'm trying to figure out he's
so passionate and he wants to motivate
karl-anthony towns and Andrew Wiggins
and he calls out management in front of
management and saying you bleep and need
me here but then does he really want to
be there in the first place it seems as
if he doesn't and I think the
relationship between Townsel iggins is a
big reason why to me and Butler is he's
kind of an extension of Syd Bedell on
the court those two have been they've
had a good relationship overall since
Wyler came into the league about seven
eight years ago and you know III don't
think he sees that same kind of
competitive fire that that drive that
will to win in towns and Wiggins that he
has and if he if he's true his word that
he really wants to win I don't think he
sees that he can do that with those two
guys that he needs to find another
situation now you can look at his list
of prefer exactly Chris I know I'm with
you here you can look at it list of
preferred teams when you scratch your
head do you say well if you really want
to win why are you picking the Knicks
the nets and to a lesser extent the
Clippers why why are these why are these
your team's and why is Miami now
suddenly in play with Dwyane Wade on his
last season so there's a lot of mixed
messages here I'm not sure what it's all
about in the end only he really knows
that and and even he is sending mixed
messages about what he wants do you
think this was all scripted yesterday
there's nothing elements of it that was
scripted you know I don't think ESPN
just randomly shows up and then Butler
doesn't come back to practice that
particular day all on a coincidence so I
do think that there was some element of
orchestration to it but you know this
this is uh this is how the sausage is
made in some of these situations you
know it's it's a definite PR move you
know we hadn't heard from from Jimmy
throughout this whole process and he
wanted to make a statement in a big way
and this is how he did it what happens
today
timbrels were supposed to have practice
at about noon or what o'clock and then
we were supposed to have media
availability after practice so you know
we're thinking we're gonna be hearing
from some players that we're gonna be
hearing from Citadel but we just got a
message a few minutes ago that they
can't go back this today and so they're
off to Milwaukee to play a preseason
game on Friday and now this is going to
be lingering kind of in the public
narrative for the next 24 hours with
nobody to respond to it nobody to
downplay it nobody to talk about it and
they'll go to Milwaukee for their game
on Friday where it's still gonna be an
issue and we'll see if Jimmy Butler's
there he did tell ESPN that he would
practice today if there was a practice
so it'll be interesting to see if he
actually suits up tomorrow night in
Milwaukee good what good luck with the
season good luck with the job there
Chris we appreciate your time thank you
dad appreciate it Chris I'm Minneapolis
star-tribune
covering the Minnesota Timberwolves he
just started covering the timber Wolf's
in recent weeks you imagine that you
walk right into them for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]